[Music]
the Grammys are this Sunday and today
true story CBS's lawyers sent an email
to musicians that are going to perform
in the Grammys that said please avoid
exposing bare fleshy under curves of the
buttocks and buttock crack of course I
get the same email from TBS before every
show but they didn't send it today
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what he was pointing at me for
you're gonna take your pants off let me
see those bare flesh on your curb that
would make a great sex yeah show me the
bare fleshy under curve of your buttocks
send I've gotten that you know next
year's Superbowl is already in the news
yeah
next year's Superbowl takes place in New
Jersey the NFL says it wants to prevent
another blackout yeah this will involve
keeping Governor Chris Christie away
from his microwave
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you for that psychotic
reaction booze melting into applause I
love that more fallout from the halftime
show Beyonce's publicist is busy trying
to get seven unflattering photos of
Beyonce removed from the internet
now the publicist is is the publicist is
described by friends as hard-working and
new to the Internet who gets a photo
back from the internet I don't know I'm
gonna get those back and then no one
will ever see him a member of Congress
is criticizing Steven Spielberg after he
discovered parts of the movie Lincoln
are historically inaccurate yeah
particularly the scene where Lincoln
dies in the mouth of a great white shark
that part breast augmentation surgery
now you're listening breasts breast
augmentation surgery is now the most
common plastic surgery procedure in the
United States guys still not a great
last minute Valentine's Day gift
ladies don't like that happy Valentine's
Day let's get those straightened out all
right let's get a bicycle pump on those
what do you say there's a new smartphone
app that lets you communicate with your
houseplants yeah yeah the app is called
I will die alone applaud I wasn't asking
you to but thank you I just thought it's
funny that people like dying alone yeah
let's get behind that yesterday the
Kansas Supreme Court ruled that
strippers can collect unemployment
however they cannot ask the clerk at the
unemployment office to make it rain not
allowed to do that
that's right true story strippers can
now collect unemployment yeah of course
if you're a stripper who can't get work
you're probably in the wrong profession
someone's like no no no put your clothes
back on